-Il n'a jamais fait
le coup de poing à l'école,
mais il pratique la politique
comme un sport de combat,
au point d'avoir déclenché
un des incidents de séance
les plus marquants
du début de législature.
Générique
...
Bonjour, Aurélien Saintoul.
-Bonjour.
-On a tous étudié
les fables
de La Fontaine, mais il n'y a
qu'un agrégé de lettres classiques
pour transformer une fable
en arme politique.
Revoyons votre prise de parole
au nom de La France Insoumise
pendant le projet de loi
sur le pouvoir d'achat.
Vous aviez pris pour cible
le Rassemblement National.
-On connaît la stratégie
de l'extrême droite
qui agit comme la chauve-souris
de la fable.
Dans le parti des oiseaux,
elle montre ses ailes.
Dans le parti des fachos,
elle montre son poil
et elle est un rat.
Vous ne connaissez pas La Fontaine,
peut-être.
Vous ne connaissez pas La Fontaine.
-Non mais monsieur...
Huées
S'il vous plaît.
Ils tapent sur leur pupitre.
-Je pense que vous vous comportez
comme des zadistes
et vous risquez de dégrader
le mobilier national.
La présidente tape sur son bureau.
-S'il vous plaît.
-Je ne vous ai pas insultés,
mais caractérisés.
-On voit que votre prise de parole
a mis en colère
vos collègues du RN.
C'est assez étonnant.
Vous avez un ton calme,
on s'attend pas à ce que
vous portiez des coups aussi rudes.
Ca fait partie de vous ?
Vous aimez provoquer
vos adversaires ?
-Non.
Je me suis jamais considéré
comme un provocateur.
En revanche, là,
en l'occurrence,
je trouvais que
c'était exact et précis.
L'extrême droite est fascisante.
-"Parti des fachos",
"zadistes",
puis assimiler le RN
au "parti des rats",
c'est quand même
extrêmement violent.
Vous êtes au bord
de la ligne rouge.
-Là, en l'occurrence,
le sujet ce jour-là,
c'était l'hypocrisie
du Rassemblement National
qui, d'un côté, parle de lutter
contre l'islamisme, etc.
Et puis, moi, j'avais suivi
dans le débat présidentiel
en particulier les questions
de défense nationale,
et j'avais lu le programme
de Marine Le Pen
sur la défense nationale.
Il était question
de renforcer les alliances
avec l'Arabie saoudite, le Qatar,
les Emirats arabes unis.
C'était cette hypocrisie
que je voulais pointer.
Je trouvais que c'était amusant,
et c'est une référence
qui m'est venue.
J'imaginais pas
que ça provoquerait cette réaction.
-Quand on vous entend citer
La Fontaine,
les mots sont une arme
en politique ?
-Bien sûr.
On est dans un débat public
qui est souvent un peu corseté,
où on cherche à se faire entendre,
donc si on peut piquer l'intérêt,
soit par la curiosité,
le bon mot...
Dans le débat public en France
en particulier,
on se cache
derrière son petit doigt,
on a peur des mots.
En l'occurrence,
dire que l'extrême droite,
ce sont des fachos,
le mot est un peu familier,
mais il est rigoureux et juste
du point de vue analytique,
si vous me permettez
un mot un peu pompeux.
-On va remonter le fil
de votre histoire.
Au collège, vous étiez
le souffre-douleur
des autres, le bon élève
chahuté par le reste de la classe,
sauf qu'à 13 ans,
même si on manie bien les mots,
ça suffit pas pour se défendre.
Est-ce que c'est une période
qui a laissé des traces en vous ?
-Je crois
que ce qui reste en moi,
c'est une forme de compréhension
et de bienveillance.
Je suis pas
du parti des winners.
C'est quelque chose
qui est très loin de moi.
J'ai eu la chance
de pouvoir grandir,
de pouvoir être un adulte
qui fait face, et ça,
c'est une bonne chose.
En revanche, je suis très sceptique
devant les gens qui croient
qu'il y a des winners, des gagnants,
des perdants, des riens.
Tout ça, ça me met
même pas mal à l'aise,
je désapprouve totalement
et c'est loin de ma culture.
-Vous avez eu
un parcours scolaire brillant :
lauréat du concours général
en version latine,
une classe prépa
au lycée Louis-le-Grand à Paris,
agrégé de lettres classiques.
On pourrait penser
que vous êtes issu
d'un milieu favorisé,
ce qui n'est pas le cas :
"J'ai la conscience de classe.
J'ai vécu
"des moments de honte sociale."
C'est là qu'il faut chercher
les racines
de votre engagement politique ?
-En grande partie, oui.
J'ai grandi dans un milieu
disons populaire,
pour faire un peu vite.
J'ai été confronté
à l'inégalité,
à la difficulté sociale.
Une des premières choses
que j'ai dites
à Jean-Luc Mélenchon,
j'étais jeune militant :
"Les gens se rendent pas compte
"que quand on est pauvre,
on a une charge mentale
"beaucoup plus importante."
On se baisse systématiquement
pour acheter le prix le moins cher.
On calcule tout le temps.
A la moindre tuile,
tout part à vau-l'eau.
Ce genre d'expérience,
je l'ai vécu dans mon enfance.
J'ai vu ce que c'était,
donc j'ai été assez conscient
des inégalités.
Et en grandissant,
je me suis rendu compte
que ceux qui dirigeaient,
souvent, n'étaient pas
les meilleurs.
C'était frappant pour moi.
-Vos parents n'ont jamais été
encartés dans un parti
ou membres d'un syndicat,
or ils ont aujourd'hui
un fils député
et un autre responsable syndical
chez Force Ouvrière,
votre frère
Matthieu Saintoul.
Comment vous expliquez ça ?
-Je sais pas.
-Il y a un terreau ?
-Oui, il y a
un terreau d'éducation.
Je pense qu'on a eu une éducation
qui nous rend disponibles...
-A l'engagement.
-A l'engagement,
et puis
on se sent concernés.
On pense qu'on a
une certaine responsabilité
à ne pas laisser le monde
tourner à l'envers
comme en ce moment.
-Vous dites :
"Lui, c'est l'ouvrier.
"Moi, c'est l'intello."
Ca donne l'impression
que vous êtes
de deux mondes séparés.
-Non,
mais on est très complémentaires.
Ce serait hypocrite de dire
qu'on a le même parcours,
la même vie, etc.
On est très proches.
Au contraire, je crois
qu'on s'enrichit mutuellement
énormément. On garde...
J'ai un parcours académique,
mon frère non,
mais je lui ai,
d'une certaine façon,
donné un point de vue
sur ce monde-là,
de la même façon
que lui est en prise
beaucoup plus directe
avec le monde du travail,
il m'a appris
énormément de choses.
-Vous avez commencé
à militer
au Parti de gauche en 2009
avec votre frère.
Vous faites partie
de cette nouvelle génération
de députés de La France Insoumise
apparue en 2022
à l'Assemblée.
On va voir une photo,
je vous ai associé
à cinq autres députés
de La France Insoumise.
Vous devez savoir pourquoi.
On y voit Damien Maudet,
Arnaud Le Gall,
David Guiraud, Clémence Guetté
et Anne Stambach-Terrenoir.
-On a tous travaillé
soit pour des députés,
soit pour des groupes,
des élus.
-Vous avez tout été collaborateurs
parlementaires à l'Assemblée,
au Parlement européen
ou au groupe de La France Insoumise.
Moi, ça me surprend un peu
parce que LFI est souvent présenté
comme le parti antisystème, et là,
ça donne l'impression que LFI
mise... pas sur des professionnels
de la politique,
mais des gens pas loin de l'être.
Est-ce que c'est pas un peu
contradictoire ?
-Il faut prendre le sujet
dans l'autre sens.
Je connais pas en détail
la vie de mes collègues
et camarades,
mais pour ce qui me concerne,
je suis devenu
assistant parlementaire
parce que j'ai été militant,
et pas l'inverse.
J'ai pas rejoint un parti politique
parce qu'il m'a donné à manger.
-C'était pas
pour faire carrière.
-Non.
-On va s'attarder
sur l'épisode le plus marquant
de votre début de mandat.
Pendant le débat
sur la réforme
des retraites, vous vous êtes
adressé à Olivier Dussopt
pour dénoncer l'augmentation
du nombre de morts
au travail.
-Vous ne pouvez pas arriver ici
et me dire que la suppression
des CHSCT n'a eu aucun effet.
Ce sont 150 orphelins,
veufs, veuves en plus,
et vous avez la responsabilité
de ces choix politiques.
Vous êtes un imposteur
et un assassin.
Cris et huées
J'ai eu il y a quelques instants
à ce micro
des mots que l'émotion
et l'emportement
m'ont fait mal choisir
et qui sont déplacés.
Je souhaite évidemment
les retirer
et adresser des excuses
publiques au ministre,
et je me tiens à sa disposition
pour avoir un échange plus personnel
et lui présenter
à nouveau mes excuses.
-Vous qui maniez la langue française
avec subtilité,
vous qui aimez bien
la finesse de la langue française,
là, vous qualifiez un ministre
d'assassin.
Qu'est-ce qui s'est passé ?
-Les images
sont assez claires.
Je suis en colère.
Dans la séquence
qui précède, j'évoque,
au sujet de la réforme
des retraites, le fait que le risque
d'accidents mortels au travail
augmente de façon explicite
avec l'âge des salariés.
Donc je lui demande ce qu'il a prévu
pour les personnes
qui vont rester au travail
et donc risquer de mourir.
Le gouvernement précédent
avait déjà supprimé les CHSCT,
donc les comités hygiène
et sécurité au travail,
et donc le nombre des accidents
mortels au travail a déjà augmenté.
Donc il ne peut pas balayer ça
d'un revers de la main.
Et c'est précisément ce qu'il fait.
Il me dit
que mes chiffres sont faux.
-Et le mot "assassin" sort
comme ça ?
Vous l'aviez pas préparé ?
-Pas du tout.
Ce que j'ai à la main,
c'est une petite fiche
sur laquelle il y a
les chiffres exacts
du nombre de morts au travail.
En fait, le mot "assassin"
était impropre
parce que, évidemment,
le ministre du Travail
n'est pas responsable directement
de la mort des gens,
mais il y a quelque chose
qui est important
et qui est bien connu
dans le débat public,
c'est la part de responsabilité
des politiques.
On peut être responsable
mais pas coupable.
Donc évidemment,
M. Dussopt n'est pas
et ne sera pas coupable
de la mort directement
des personnes,
mais quand on a des responsabilités,
il faut savoir les regarder en face.
Si des gens meurent au travail
du fait de décisions politiques,
il faut savoir le voir.
-Qu'est-ce qui vous a poussé
à présenter vos excuses
comme vous l'avez fait ?
La séance a été interrompue.
Vous êtes revenu à la reprise
pour présenter vos excuses.
-D'abord, je voulais pas
que le débat s'éternise
sur cet aspect,
et puis à titre personnel,
j'aime avoir des mots
les plus exacts possibles,
donc "assassin",
c'était pas le mot le plus exact.
-Comment vous expliquez
que ce soit très rare de voir
des hommes politiques s'excuser ?
-Parce que s'excuser...
Si la bonne foi caractérisait
le débat public,
je pense qu'on hésiterait moins
à s'excuser.
Le problème...
-Est-ce que c'est pas aussi
une question d'ego ?
-Non. Honnêtement,
je crois pas qu'on soit tous bourrés
d'un ego démesuré.
Dans le débat public...
Ce qui est aussi intéressant,
c'est de voir qu'après ces excuses,
le ministre dit
qu'il n'accepte pas mes excuses.
On ne voit pas la façon
dont il est sorti
de l'hémicycle juste avant
en proférant des injures
à mon égard.
Mais c'est pas grave, je...
Si on avait eu juste un échange
de personne à personne...
-Vous l'invitiez
à avoir cet échange,
il n'a jamais eu lieu.
-C'est pas grave.
Personne n'a envie d'être ami
avec l'un ou l'autre.
Mais pourquoi on s'excuse pas ?
Parce que, d'une certaine façon,
le risque que, en face,
on abuse de votre excuse
est très important.
-On va passer à notre quiz.
Vous allez devoir compléter
les phrases que je vais
vous proposer.
Si Cyril Hanouna m'invite
dans TPMP...
Je dis ça parce que
vous êtes en guerre contre Bolloré.
Vous êtes
rapporteur
d'une commission d'enquête.
-Je suis pas en guerre du tout.
-Vous visez les médias Bolloré.
-Si j'étais invité,
j'irais pas.
En revanche, peut-être qu'il viendra
devant ma commission d'enquête.
-Vous espérez ?
-C'est en réflexion.
Ce qui est intéressant, c'est que
les programmes de Cyril Hanouna
sont ceux qui ont fait
le plus souvent l'objet de sanctions
ou de rappels à l'ordre de l'Arcom.
Moi, je travaille sur ce sujet,
la façon dont les chaînes
respectent ou pas
leurs obligations
et dont elles sont contrôlées
par l'Arcom.
Je suis quand même curieux
de savoir
ce que Cyril Hanouna
a pu répondre à l'Arcom
quand on lui a dit qu'il a abusé.
Peut-être qu'on l'auditionnera.
-Quand je sens monter la colère
pendant un débat à l'Assemblée...
-Ah...
L'expérience
de l'"assassin" me fait dire
que j'ai appris...
-Vous respirez un bon coup ?
-...à respirer un peu,
mais cette colère est légitime,
elle est partagée
par énormément de nos concitoyens,
donc elle doit pas
faire dépasser les bornes,
mais elle doit pouvoir aussi
s'exprimer.
-Enfin,
comme disait Pline le Jeune...
là, je teste votre maîtrise,
ce qui reste du latiniste
que vous êtes.
-Je vais pas avoir
de citation spécifique
de Pline le Jeune.
C'est un peu spécifique.
Si on doit avoir
une citation latine,
j'aime bien celle de Térence :
"Je suis humain
"et rien de ce qui est humain
ne m'est étranger."
C'est une bonne base
pour fonder
l'universalisme politique
que je défends.
-Ce sera le mot de la fin.
Merci.
-Merci à vous.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA
Générique
...